welcome to this video poker poker poker
okay hmm let's see let's do some other
opening yeah that's a green pawn opening
early bird g5 okay but it looks like we
are going to transpose into a queen's
gambit why not Queens gambit declined um
hmm normally play it like that but not
another I never was sure what the right
way is he a Quincy to Roxy one there are
there are many many decent blinds yeah
this is in fact rather okay for black
okay okay so he's happy to go for this i
QP position which is some not very
ambitious for black but on the other
hand rather solid I had a very
comparable position against em ranh to
make Umi on in my Grandmaster hanh
nguyen in my tournament in late october
early november two thousand fourteen and
numb the very air and it was almost
almost the same thing okay i'm going to
play this move get out of this sem the
see file
okay so he's centralizing the snide an
interesting question now I can play look
before maybe this is an idea piling up
this way on the devo up to 41 okay
that's not a very aggressive looking so
let's do that I know that I'm not going
to win this pawn easily but piling up on
it is the first step and maybe I have
chances to increase this pressure a
little bit 9210 is a move that comes to
mind a nitrate would of course be be
very welcome if you trade tonight we
will have an entirely static position
where I have located his son his pawn
very reliably so he as I expected
retreated tonight now I'm going to show
me a three putting some pressure on this
pawn what I now want is I really want
the knight on c3 em quid a one-night be
193 there's a very artificial way of
regrouping yeah not another way that
that looks very natural but why am
here why a c1 e to this looks far more
far more attractive I wonder if
Nigeria's a move I can also think of in
a look T 2 nite deform and not see one
that's also night g-forces yeah but it's
not an i came it is a slight problem
okay maybe maybe I do this after all
with the night coming to deform not so
much to blow Kate but to go to each went
to see three ultimately according to the
would Bend Larson motto you should you
shouldn't block eight the IQ piece you
should try to capture it okay Nigel
pfizer move that surprised me one point
was also that this is not possible and
now I have a nice blockade a really nice
blockade and I have night against bishop
the somewhat clumsy bishop ERG form plus
I have chances that ok I don't get the
secret intake yeah you can take here and
play rook c8 in fact yeah but ok this is
so ultimately very convenient position
to play
I'm surprised that you allowed Quincy
five actually or is Queenie for no good
maybe for Queen B 1
should h3 is an interesting question i
can even play g3 yeah the thing is
should what do i want to play that or
not Queen g3 is of course this is
forcing the Queen trade not sure forcing
the true Queen traders of course leading
to a very one-sided position but is it a
position that I can win that's the
problem normally and black is able to
hold this this kind of thing and i'm not
i'm not sure about g3 check so i'm going
to force them the Queen trade play there
the simple simple method so my king is
going up here I wonder maybe I can try
to for some concession on the queenside
ok I can give the check now and go to d4
which is probably check desirable that I
get to default and now yeah how do I and
get ahead Knight to c3 probably start
with that
right age 5 this is something that would
be nice so he's handling stopping that
okay if I go g4s 393 it looks
counterintuitive really does and let me
think about this for a moment
it's not leading to much
check stairway forward to wonder
difficult that's probably a bit too
ambitious to what I do here check maybe
a jazz which are winning a pawn
check no I'm blundering the pawn I have
to play a seven I forgot a 70 I know
just giving it away like that check yeah
stupid stuff okay a seven first of
course game drawn yeah I forgot I
somebody forgot to play the movie I have
to play a seven first of course a seven
Bishop e7 Nyjah for King here and that
said I mean everything this is this is
the easiest movement and it's just a
very simple win ah ok yeah just forgot
to play a seven when I was I was just
seeing ok I get the Knight to g4 but i
forgot to insert that the move here the
a7 move yeah it was a an endgame where
this kind of endgame this is always a
bit better for white but it's normally
not a win like he's able to defend it I
I somehow managed to to trick him a
little bit here with my my maneuvers not
sure if they were really good this
should have won our strong mayor and
here all of a sudden here this is
getting getting very problematic as I
have this as well and TM chan chan is
just he is just losing but i really i
forgot to to insert and notes insert the
a7 there is seven months now yeah it was
a bit surprising that here the T played
naija for this is helping me quite quite
a lot yeah and this this leads to a
super one-sided position where black
will be suffering for them for the rest
of the game and probably the Queen g3
thing that i did is something that
probably i can improve yes what i'm
trying to say actually even that might
be possible yeah something the bishop
doesn't have any good squares this is
much better here for check ya here this
is as well as was apparent very
one-sided but maybe it is just to draw
it's very likely okay thanks for
watching